Kim Kardashian calls out sister Khloe  during the family's Costa Rican getaway  you're just so like you're so annoying  it's like Chava up in a new promo for  Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians  the family is vacationing in beautiful  Costa Rica but it clearly wasn't all  sunshine waterfalls and sexy photo  shoots in the pool oh you people know  Chloe felt the fam wasn't spending  enough time together doing fun  activities during the vacay just because  I was afraid of the whitewater rafting  like what's the point of making it not  fun for the Hangout you know I always  thought me and Kim sure wasn't afraid to  speak her mind here is a negative one  just saying how awful we are and how  this you're like a big bully it's all  about the sisters seem to work things  out eventually as they posted plenty of  snaps together throughout the rest of  the trip  you